c'est une tendance qui consiste à
conduire à compter son nombre de
conquêtes sauf que ça peut créer des
problèmes de coupe cercle quand avec une
nouvelle meuf tu lui dis ou un nouveau
mec tu dis voilà j'ai pécho ton de mec
ou de meuf forcément moi à chaque fois
que je peux jouer une meuf elle me fait
toujours le même truc
ça y est
j'ai enfin fini une main tu étais le 5e
alors ça ça arrive tout le temps
et donc on va regarder ça on va
récapituler après qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez est-ce qu'il faut le dire ou pas
le dire bien entendu Gilles je pense
qu'avec Fatou vous êtes dit les choses
oui d'accord
tu lui as dit toi ton nombre de
conquêtes c'est quoi ton par exemple
environ une centaine
[Rires]
laissant je veux bien les trouver un
avis de recherche
si lui la pêche au 100 meuf mon frère
toi tu as péché sans meuf toi c'est des
obligeant que vous soyez surpris et
c'est surtout
grâce à lucide
pas qu'est-ce que les meufs l'ont péché
aussi parce que lui peut-être que une
meuf si tu as vu une meuf que tu as vu à
la télé
pourquoi vous mettez en deux trois
paroles
depuis peu une nouvelle tendance et un
nouveau terme sont apparus sur les
réseaux sociaux le body counts
ce mot anglais repris massivement sur
internet a pour but de compter et donc
de révéler le nombre de conquêtes que
nous avons eu au cours de notre vie
voici zéro deux trois quatre plus 30
mais ces dernières heures une théorie
perçue comme sexiste par certains semble
prendre de l'ampleur sur les réseaux
sociaux quand une fille dit son nombre
de partenaires la règle c'est qu'il faut
multiplier par 4 et par les hommes il
faut diviser par deux sur Twitter
nombreux sont ceux qui postent
aujourd'hui des messages affirmant que
cette théorie est bien réelle et qu'ils
ont déjà menti ou découvert un mensonge
de leur bien-aimé sur le nombre réel de
leurs relations passées alors selon vous
faut-il être honnête avec son ou sa
partenaire
faut-il être honnête avec sa partenaire
Hugo tu dis non et je suis comme je te
comprends je vois pas trop l'intérêt
ça apporte pas grand chose au couple et
en plus je souligne que c'est souvent
une différence de traitement entre les
hommes et les femmes parce qu'un homme
est un donjon quand il a plein de
conquêtes il va peut-être gonfler alors
que la parlé de jus là peut-être par
exemple
à moins de rire le nombre ayant peur de
passer pour des filles faciles je trouve
c'est un petit peu
dis-moi qui t'a pécho je te dirai qui tu
es aussi ah oui il y a ce vieil adage
attention c'est pas dis-moi quelle
musique tu écoutes je te dirais que tu
as non c'est moi qui t'appelle tout à
l'heure dis-moi
ce que tu manges je te dirai quel si tu
as un cochon des trucs comme ça
[Rires]
dis-moi
juste après
ils ont vécu un peu après
il avait quand même
[Applaudissements]
la seule la seule normalement quand tu
pécho un mec ou une meuf tu fais je
t'appelle un je t'appelle uber Daniel
c'est la seule meuf je t'appelle une
ambulance
[Rires]
à la fin
merci alors il faut tout déclarer avant
c'est comme les impôts c'est très
important parce que sinon si vous faites
griller
au fur et à mesure du temps vous rendez
meuf voilà il faut déclarer la vérité
vous c'est 8 par exemple et si jamais
vous croisez un partenaire non déclaré
par rapport au resto après vous rentrez
dans une vague de Somme vous nagez dans
le somme vous êtes jaloux pendant toute
la relation et moi j'ai mis au point une
méthode de calcul pour calculer le vrai
nom d'EXE de votre meuf vous faites son
nombre d'exéclarés plus sa taille en
centimètres moins son poids divisé par
[Applaudissements]
ça veut dire que tu mets déjà sur le
même niveau une vraie belle histoire et
le coup d'un soir mais non je suis
désolé j'ai envie de savoir et que ma
meuf sache combien de copines
[Rires]
donc franchement je trouve que c'est
juste stupide et ça n'a aucun intérêt
parce que l'autre va se comparer il va
dire à l'instant
moi alors moi tu sais quoi ça
je suis tellement sûr de moi
c'est vrai que à chaque fois je dis tu
es sorti c'est vrai que tu es sorti
qu'avec des tricards et je le pense
vraiment en plus tous ces ex je te dis
vraiment c'est vrai que j'ai dit souvent
c'est fou tu es passé d'une Corsa une
Bentley toi non mais je veux pas je le
dis vraiment en plus
quand tu vas rouler quand tu vas rouler
en Renault 5 ça va te faire tout drôle
je peux te le dire mais vous voulez
qu'elle vous dise la vérité vous voulez
qu'elle vous mentent
alors moi j'ai un truc c'est vrai que
j'ai une humilité incroyable
pour moi voilà je veux dire à chaque
fois je dis bon écoute c'est vrai que
voilà la vie t'as pas épargné
aujourd'hui voilà aujourd'hui je suis là
voilà tu dis c'est voilà c'est quoi tu
as une chance sur un Binard c'est comme
si tu avais gagné l'Euro Millions c'est
génial voilà
valorisez pas leur passé sans vous
dites pas c'est bien ce que tu as vécu
mais maintenant c'est autre chose
il y a des catastrophes
donc vous êtes un sauveur en fait
exactement
j'avoue et je le pense en plus vraiment
mais je le pense vraiment je le pense
vraiment de l'humilité
et je dis que c'est toujours dit que
c'était une de mes qualités voilà j'ai
jamais caché il y a Ibrahimovic chez moi
donc l'humanité voilà c'est tout voilà
on se ressemble
la question vous lui dites tu as eu
combien de mecs avant moi
je connais un peu les les mecs voilà et
je lui dis voilà
Cyril Hanouna c'est 8 et Gilles Verdun
c'est 100
erreur
des surprises il y a un des deux Mythos
quand même
hyper flatteur d'être avec un mec qui me
dit qu'il a eu 51 ans
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous voilà vedovélique est-ce
que tu demandes
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que j'en pense non moi je
pense que c'est un sombre bourbier de
raconter sa vie passée parce que ça
regarde absolument pas la personne
déclarer il faut déclarer
tu dis tu repars par hasard moi je
connais l'ex de Benaim très sympa
d'ailleurs je connais le nouveau et je
connais très certainement le prochain
on a du pif hein ça fait pas plaisir que
j'ai pas compris c'est que si toutefois
ex sont avec des tocards et vous dites
que dis-moi avec qui tu es sorti je te
dirai qui tu es mais alors ça veut dire
que vous êtes sortis qu'avec des nanas
qui vous intéressait pas parce que non
alors
je vais dire un moment tu sais qu'est-ce
que vous avez fait alors
en voiture tu te trompes de chemin tu te
trompes de cheminée
la personne de par rapport à ses ex ben
qu'est-ce que vous faites avec toutes
ces personnes qui ont été avec tous ces
ex mais je reste pas avec elle
grâce en fait si avec vous elles ont été
touchées par la grâce
mais du coup elles sont remettent jamais
c'est de difficile vous êtes le Attila
du cul
non mais oh ça va pas
tiens toi tu as eu combien de meuf toi
parce que toi on sait jamais toi je vais
vous dire alors soit vous parlez des
histoires de fesses ça vous parlez
tout ah non c'est très important mais
qu'est-ce qu'on s'en fout une époque
quand j'étais jeune le sexe pour le sexe
oui bien sûr j'ai pas compté mais
maintenant à peu près oh non mais pas
grand chose ne paye pas un dragueur
sincèrement en tout cas en amour 5
personnes j'ai 5 personnes vraiment
comme tu te fous de ma gueule toi aimer
du coup
tu as couché
ce que tu veux tu veux demander à ton
zizi et on n'a pas l'air
[Musique]
le compteur est plus important 855
je sais pas
[Applaudissements]
ça me paraît bizarre quand même parce
qu'il a dit qu'il a commencé à 7h vers
18 ans il a 58 ça fait plus de 200 par
an
ouais
j'ai l'impression de poser problème
j'avoue que oui vous posez pas j'ai eu
des périodes je suis souvent en couple
mais j'ai eu des périodes de célibat
très active
mais j'étais l'égérie de 36-15 Aline
c'était frénétique
je suis même devenu ami du gars qui
gérait on était tous les deux on avait
40 minitels autour de nous mais c'était
la frénésie et là peut-être sur une
période de trois mois et ben j'ai dû
coucher ça fait 90 jours 70 jours
[Applaudissements]
arrête arrête
donc on a quoi alors toi donc 30 toi non
moi des amoureux parce que là
au-dessus de Gilles une quinzaine
[Applaudissements]
une vingtaine
une trentaine
bon et 60
[Applaudissements]
je suis absident depuis un an donc je
suis avec ma copine je suis retiré du
jeu je suis qu'avec ma copine donc je
suis accident non je suis absent
à peu près 8 comme vous
bougez pas moi
vous avez juste embrassé les deux
dernières c'est que ça fait 6 en vrai
bon allez j'ai plus envie de savoir